good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy monday it is a nasty
misty and gloomy monday here in new york
but our spirits cannot be broken our
spirits are high
considering the atmosphere is low my
spirit is high because doctor faceman is
here and usually he doesn't come in on a
rainy day because
he doesn't [ __ ] with the rain like that
beautiful coat of hair just too special
it will not do but he is here therefore
i am cheered the love of my life is here
and i really brought him for you i find
it
it's so difficult to like get theo out
and about in the rain because he just
gets wet and he's like a mop and he's
all
soppy but if i may he can
make it through the rain he
can stand up once again
on his own and he knows
that he's lipstick on ntc yeah sorry
i was trying not to embarrass you but
giving you like a little tongue on the
teeth
it's okay i just finished mariah carey's
memoir so i've just been
in mariah carey's canon got it
and i have a newfound appreciation for
that song and everything mariah the book
is amazing five stars out of five
uh so so good so powerful
never been done before never to be done
again mixed up in a blender
just really give birth to it like her
story is so interesting obviously she's
an interesting woman
but the way it's told it's like she is
in on every single piece of her life
yeah i there were so many interesting
pop culture tidbits
the stories behind so many of her songs
she writes and like produces every
single one of her songs yeah that's not
something that's a given for from like
your 90s pop star
for really any pop star these days it's
actually shocking how many of them have
like nothing to do with the songwriting
process but their name is on the list of
songwriters because they were like
in the building yeah no she's so
dedicated to the craft always has been
always will be
and i thought it was an amazing story
and so if you love a celebrity memoir
which we all do aces is that what you
spent most of your weekend doing that's
what i spent saturday doing i finished
it saturday then saturday night we had
our
let's go let's go
cause it's a girl's night it's all right
we had a girls night it was slightly
derailed we really don't want to get
into it we don't want to get into like
why it was derailed here's the bottom
line we had an amazing night like
the energy was there the girls had their
night
out um but there were some derailments
you know due to
like the fact that it's hard to get
stuff done these days you know we're
just living in unprecedented times and
which is an unprecedented evening and
what jackie and i don't want to do is
like come on here and like trash
you know an institution like drag a
restaurant that's not what we're going
to do
we're not going to do that and we're
still not going to do it no
100 it goes against everything we
believe in i would never but i just
really want to
yeah but we won't but we're not going to
but we won't um
so but the rest of the night was like so
much fun it's been so long since we've
had like
the band back together band back
together an energetic night out like
that so
yesterday i was obviously down for the
count but
strangely i didn't i didn't hear from
you and i was just assuming you were
dead
so strangely i wasn't dead like i
actually didn't have a headache all day
but mentally physically emotionally
spiritually
eggs house did like couldn't think
couldn't speak couldn't move so i was
just in bed all day
um people i didn't hear i didn't hear
from you and it was like five o'clock
and i facetimed zach and i'm like
is your wife alive because like i didn't
hear from you all damn like i dropped
you off but like did you ever make it
upstairs
and he was like she's asleep yes so um
i was you know milling about around two
o'clock i put on the movie clouds
oh i was watching the movie clouds from
two o'clock to nine o'clock oh because
i at 2 30 fell asleep for three hours
that's probably when you called
and then i got up made dinner
zach and i watched snl what'd you uh
make um so i made this like fiber
gourmet mac and cheese
but it was mac and cheese it was
actually pretty good and not super
caloric but it was like i was having a
cheat day
but not the worst it could have been
reason within reason right
um watched snl shower took a bath
finally made it back to clouds to finish
the movie and the end was actually good
okay good um but it took forever yeah no
i um i watched snl as well we're gonna
recap it tv recap we also have potomac
to recap
today um anything else you watched
uh let me tell you any c use for the
group any what content uppers
uh no i actually sh oh yes
i watched so much jeopardy literally me
and ben started
um keeping score of how many answers we
got right
per episode and i beat on set on
saturday i beat my highest record from
friday i got 21 answers right in one
episode of jeopardy isn't that good
mm-hmm
yeah so i'm just feeling really proud of
myself and starting this week i'm gonna
try again and try again and implement
the seven o'clock jeopardy game into my
everyday routine
but we'll see if i remember because like
i said seven o'clock is an important
time for me
i'm thinking about dinner i'm thinking
about bed like i just don't know if i
can fit jeopardy into my schedule but
i'm going to try
yeah i think that would be a good thing
for your inner peace sometimes like it's
not the most convenient thing
but it's you've got to make make choices
and you've just got to make it work
life is about choices it truly is um but
this show is going to be great today yes
and we actually have a really exciting
week ending the week with
toasterween 2020. i'm getting really
excited my wig came in the mail today
for toast halloween
and i actually don't think it's the
right color but thank god i planned
early i can get another one
um i'm very excited i think that i've
been seeing what people think we're
gonna do and
upon coming up with ideas those
suggestions definitely
were part of what we were already
thinking but i don't know if anyone's
gonna guess what we're doing
yeah and it i'm really really excited
now that we finally like cemented our
idea
agreed everything's been ordered now i'm
so excited
me too because you know what i don't
want to overhype it though because yeah
cause you never come and see
and you know what we're now going three
years in a row with like unbelievable
halloweens
and after every year we're like this
probably will be the one that's like not
the best because we just keep
outdoing ourselves we really do and it's
like maybe this is the year where like
we don't outdo ourselves you know maybe
but you know what's crazy about
toasterween like
it's really improv comedy like yes and
that's why we can't just we can't know
if it's going to be good because it's
not about the costumes like even when we
were
kim and courtney like people dress up as
the kardashians it's like not that's
like a basic idea not a great costume in
general but it's what we do with it on
the show and like
how are the personalities like influence
the show and so it's really improv
sketch comedy like
i feel like i could be on snl honestly
so
how would you rank our past three
costumes and performances okay [ __ ]
that's really hard i think i would do
you and me dressing as each other as
number one
yeah second place head in second place
it would be jonas brothers i think so
too and then kardashians
and also because of that jonas brothers
video of us dancing like
that even if the episode stunk which it
didn't that made the toast a ween but
see i
why i think the jonas brothers um
episode was the best is because of the
improv like
i remembered it and i remember like that
video and i remember like we looked
funny
but when i actually watched us in
character as nick joe and kevin like
it was hysterical like not to to our own
horn but like
true sketch comedy at its finest and we
take sketch comedy very seriously yeah
so it's just something we could add to
our resume yeah improv
improv comedian yeah it's like we went
to second city yeah no that's good for
me because like you're a stand-up
comedian but like i can genuinely say
i'm
i do improv no you 100 you do it
she's an annual improv artist she's
really honing her craft
thank you um so i think if it's
really okay with you you think so do you
have anything else you want to recap
from the weekend that you did or enjoyed
or
played or ate no i think that's really
everything
so i guess then that would make it that
it would be time
right so i guess it is time for the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
now i am genuinely thrilled about
today's um
sponsor because it is the most us
sponsor ever
we got a huge box of products from them
last week and i've been using
them religiously you guys if it's the
sponsor i think it is you're going to
want to
keep your ears up and your mouth open we
are literally
embracing you know our roots the morning
breath today's sponsor is
therabreath the world's fastest growing
oral health care solution for one simple
reason
our products are powered and tested by
science not gimmicky marketing and
have powerful masking flavors so
literally they have chewing gum
mouthwash mints they have a million
things and the
sole goal of this company is to like
help your oral health and specifically
your breath
combat bad breath so i not only suffer
from just
awful breath like at all times i have a
very sensitive nose and like i cannot be
within a foot of ben if his breath even
remotely smells like anything unpleasant
so it honestly has been like very trying
for our relationship
and i brought home the gum and we've
been chewing it like literally
non-stop ben used his mouthwash and now
i gave him the third breath
mouthwash which is for your oral health
and it's just
it's so vastly improved our lives and i
just i could
sing about fair breath all day that's so
funny because ever since i met zach he's
been using the thera breath
mints and they are so powerful like any
time you ask like sacks if
he has a mint he'll give you one of
these thera-breath ones and they're
powerful like
bad breath and now that i started keto
last week i've been like really nervous
about my keto breath because it's like
on another level and so i've started
using the thera breath
mouthwash yeah sometimes like if i
breathe on you it's literally like my
organs are decaying and like what is
that smell
ew okay but the third breath mouthwashes
so i started implementing it in my daily
life and it is combating keto breath one
with at a time
and i'm about to blow your mind okay i'm
ready do you know that every
thera-breath product is certified kosher
vegan and gluten-free so their products
aren't just effective they're clean and
ethical too
none of their oral rinses are tested on
animals and they're all made in the usa
with the most ethically sourced
ingredients
they're so confident in their products
that each and every one is backed up by
their 100 money-back guarantee
so if you don't like them for any reason
simply contact them for a full refund
it's just really like the most fabulous
product um out there and
and i think i say that with absolute
certainty certainty and all their thera
breath
fresh breath oral rinses are 100 alcohol
free and they have no burn again that's
also kosher vegan and gluten
um their mouthwash comes in three
delicious flavors
gentle mild mint it's perfect for
sensitive mouths me too sometimes i
really can't use like spicy
mouthwashes it makes my mouth really
hard they have invigorating icing mint
which has a blast of spearmint freshness
to kick-start your morning and that
exotic rainforest mint is flavored with
essential bergamot oils for a taste like
un unlike anything else on the market be
sure to send people to therabreath.com
toast if you know someone who has bad
breath go to therabreath.com
so maybe you weren't someone who was
born with bad breath but now maybe you
have mask breath
therabreath.com thera breath is spelled
t h e r a
b r e a t h dot com slash toast
if you want to save 25 25 off your total
order from the website
use the code a toast a t o s t
therabreath.com
toast and use the promo code a toast
a-t-o-s-t
their breath is like therapy for your
breath oh
beautiful claudia that's beautiful sign
on
pow pow pow that breath okay our first
story is really the big
news of the weekend kanye west on joe
rogan
a three hour interview which is a lot
but most of joe rogan's interviews are
over three hours
so i was not i would have been surprised
if it was anything less than three hours
because we know that
kanye um is very verbose so like why
would it have been any shortening right
no it honestly could have been
i mean i watched 30 minutes and it felt
like three hours i watched about an hour
and 15 minutes on saturday i was
supposed to watch the rest yesterday but
then obviously
my plans change um i will be watching
the rest but it's just
it's incredibly interesting i mean i've
i've listened to a few episodes of joe
rogan like from start to finish and i
love them because he does video also and
i can't say that i would be able to like
watch the whole thing if it wasn't video
and that's why i love the morning toast
because we do video also and like check
us out youtube.com
morning toast if i were a toaster like i
would watch this video every single day
and like that's how i feel about joe
rogan when his guest is someone who i'm
deeply interested in
yeah so i actually i am deeply
interested in kanye
um but i this episode was just for me
it was not it like i could not
follow anything joe rogan literally said
i watched the first 30 minutes and it
was literally the same question from the
it was the first question joe rogan
asked like
connie just kept being like i don't want
to go down a rabbit hole and then
proceeded to go down a rabbit hole
and he was just so all over the place
and there was a lot that i wanted to
hear
him discuss and maybe he gets to it in
the third in the third hour
but i just am not gonna make it i mean
the question was about like
why god put it on his heart to run for
president and then he somehow ended up
talking about
engineering monasteries that are
eco-friendly like i literally had no
idea what he was talking about it was
so messy sounds related okay no it's
how is that related you watched the
first 30 minutes and i will say the
first 30 minutes were
not the most interesting but like it is
a three-hour episode so it's not fair to
judge it based on that
second of all as joe rogan eventually
distills when kanye answers a question
and like is responding to something
he looks at it from like and it's not
just like a two-dimensional question
it's like for him
five six-dimensional and like he's
looking at it from all these different
perspectives and he goes down all these
rabbit holes
like not because he's messy or all over
the place but because that's just the
way that his brain works
and ultimately like it's amazing what he
lands on and some of the ideas that he
has like
are amazing i don't know i'm not seeing
it in the way that you're seeing it
maybe um either like you're looking too
much into it or i'm not looking enough
into it
um maybe it's somewhere in the middle i
just i was not impressed
and you know my bar is so low for like
the kardashians like they fart and i'm
like that was amazing
and i truly just got so lost and then he
was just
making weird analogies about the music
industry and the metoo movement and
it was borderline offensive and i just i
couldn't get with it
and that's very rare for me because you
know i'm such a supporter of the
kardashian crew
oh i i think it just takes like patience
which which you do i have a lot of
things i have a ton of things
i do not have no it's not snackable it's
not bite-sized it's not even quotable
it's not like because the quote like the
first half of the quote
and the last half of the quote are 30
minutes apart you know because every
like everything else is like where his
mind went
during the tangent but from what i saw i
thought it was extremely interesting
there's a lot that he talks about that
like doesn't necessarily register
not or like speak to me but there's so
much that he says that just like
he can just like distill down a thought
like to its
roots and i just think so much of it was
was brilliant
okay i don't know if i would say the
word brilliant but i really appreciate
your optimism
and your your hope for him it's
beautiful no i don't need like he's good
he doesn't need my hope like
and what i always now what i now do
because i feel like in the past kanye
interviews i've just kind of been like
oh
kanye but then you go back and watch
them and it's like no no everything he
said
six years ago joggers is true look
around look what every single person is
wearing like
if i had to say what that what happened
joggers
that's what happened oh 100 and so when
he said it he sounded crazy but like
and now he's like now if you listen to
everything he says through the lens of
like one day this might be true like
it's really interesting and when he said
the part about like one of his goals is
to have like a stadium-sized
church where it's like the people the
the stan
the people in the stands are gospel
singers trained gospel singers and
you'll have like a hundred thousand
people like just
oh that's cool like singing gospel
music and what that would do for me to
get into the soul i was just like
i never heard of an idea like that
before sounds like a no [ __ ] brainerd
it sounds beautiful
kanye that's beautiful yeah yeah no
don't get me wrong there definitely were
like bits in there that were
like gems but as it as a viewer
looking for entertainment it was very
difficult to follow
i i can understand why it might not be
for everyone yeah definitely
i think there was a lot in there and i
look forward to the second half and i i
don't want to read any article to me the
news is like connie went on joe rogan
kanye has respect for the podcasting
industry joe rogan does it yet again
that's the headline to me i don't want
to do like 10 bombshells from kanye's
interview that so-and-so thought was
interesting because that's probably not
the part that i'm gonna find interesting
that's true
you know yeah so that's that on that if
you listen to it let us know your
thoughts are you a jackie or are you a
claudia
i i do think that most people are gonna
side with me on this one but i think
like the ones who side with me even
though like there might only be a
handful of us
like we see each other and you know what
like i just feel like i'm really like
nailing these popular opinions this week
like between claire and now this kanye
thing i feel like
i'm really speaker for the people i'm
speaker of the house yeah
you're speaking for the people but like
i like speaking for two
by the way i know that you like speaking
for like two people the most
unpopular opinion like i know that about
you it's what makes you great
but um just know that we know that like
you just say stuff
just for the sake of saying it yeah you
just got to get it out of course
but i don't i don't know that this is
unpopular actually i'm curious i want to
go to his youtube quickly
and see how many views the video has so
far like compared to
other videos i mean i'm sure it's very
high performing
i don't know when does youtube count the
view um
oh i don't know right now it's at six
million views and i was about to guess
around three or four million that's
where like
big like that's where a big guest
would be like around i mean but it also
just came out it's only been two days oh
it came out on a saturday like that's
crazy
yeah i was literally like sitting at my
youtube like waiting it was a few
minutes late honestly on my youtube i
think it was just my app is slow it was
because i actually watched it like at
one i was waiting for it too like wow we
have no life um i was waiting for it too
and it was out immediately it happened
to drop at the perfect time like
for my schedule yeah maybe that's why he
did it yeah perhaps
so anyways check it out let us know your
thoughts yeah i imagine listening as a
podcast is even more
like confusing yeah because it's already
like a an interview that's difficult to
follow
if if you you know it jack if you're
gonna admit it was difficult to follow
i i was following like no and no i'll
say what is frustrating is like
sometimes kanye's about to make a point
and i'm like yes yes yes and then he
goes on that tangent i'm like
what were you gonna say right like that
can we i think that actually is a
definition of difficult to follow so you
could just admit that
sure sure next story
little happy news hillary duff and
matthew coma celebrate
their daughter's second birthday after
announcing some pregnancy
news for the family very exciting this
is your third kid their third child
matthew cohen that's like i hadn't
realized until i read the headline where
this story was about to go because i
always thought we were just talking
about hillary duff
but then matthew coma of it all you know
it's like you would think that between
the two like hillary is obviously the
star of the relationship but on this but
according to the toast
can you explain okay you told me about
the matthew coma saga and i legitimately
forgot but i just know it has something
to do with zed
from what i remember we started to make
matthew coleman a verb
because like someone if you got mathy
coma it meant like your work was stolen
right right i guess like they were
partners and matthew
coma like did a lot of the producing
yeah stuff on the back end and said
obviously they got the credit for it
and then some way somehow like that took
all the credit and matthew got home but
like they were a duo or something
yeah and he got comad and that's just
like not you where you want to be got it
and what's another example you would
think of someone getting comed
oh my god i just thought of one um but i
don't want to
you don't want to insult anyone yeah
okay um wait no but i could i could do a
group project like
you can get coma like in school yeah i
could think of
another one of the two people working
together
i don't know you put me on the spot okay
sorry sorry but i just wanted to
remember where we have so many like
weird
phrases that sometimes it's hard to
remember like the origins of one
yeah and you know what i'm like i would
have completely forgotten about that
story if like
it wasn't a verb because when i just
read matthew comet i was like who's
getting robbed
right we're right but happy for hillary
duff like so happy for her she's
you know what they say like you never
know what goes on behind closed doors
but i feel like she has a pretty great
life
yeah no i i think she has a normal life
i think that's what all you can hope for
as a celebrity i feel like this week
i've watched like many
in-depth celebrity interviews due to
like dave letterman and the joe rogan
thing and yeah and i'm realizing these
um
similarities and common themes in all of
them which is like
you know just trying to have like this
normal life striving for normalcy
and so when i think when a celebrity has
something that resembles normalcy like
that to them is just you know beautiful
yeah claudia that's beautiful
i agree hillary duff is definitely one
of those people like she lives in new
york
and i feel like when you live in new
york like you're really trying to be
low-key yeah
not a lot of celebrities live in new
york no and and certainly not anymore
that was mariah's book her her penthouse
does she still have it i think that she
does but i don't feel like she lives in
in new york no she's such a diva like
she needs to sprawl
yeah but she definitely loves you know
in the occasional evening in manhattan
of course of course dinner at you know
the most fabulous restaurant in town and
then back to the penthouse
for a little late-night jacuzzi dip yeah
but she definitely lives in like a ranch
i need to go watch her mtv cribs again
now that i like know
some of the more intricate details of
the room yes i think that's a good idea
speaking of bebe news love is blind star
marquevas and girlfriend
aubry rainey are expecting their first
child so
um typically like i don't know if like
you know this would be a story
like if last year's reality tv news
would
translate to this year right even though
it was this year that's how [ __ ] long
this year has been
um we know love's blind was not in 2012
yes it was it was like in february it
was like right before
it was right before no i so you know
what was also in 2020 it's going to blow
your mind
what makes it i know because someone
just tagged me and it is
i'm sorry me too um but
mark of jessica and mark you know a
formative character in the show
he's by the way 24 years old is going to
be a dad
him and his girlfriend are expecting
their first child in april 2021.
what we found out together after a
weekend spent with friends and family in
west virginia for labor day weekend
so i mean everyone's like how's jessica
where's right she's 35.
probably doing great fantastic yeah she
never liked him to begin with right so
the thing is with marc anthony cuervas
is
i don't know who he is you know because
on the show to me he was like kind of
pathetic in the sense that he was like
so young but so badly wanted to settle
down and like
having kids is like a dream for him so i
don't know if like that's who he really
is
or the thirst monster he became
afterwards like sliding into girls dms
just like hearing shady things about him
like is that who he is because the
former that i described
would be overjoyed to be having a kid at
25 young for a man
yeah but if he's the thirst monster like
i just don't know who the real mark is
yes i agree with x i feel like what we
saw on the show was
not who he seemed to be afterwards on
social media but i feel like that's
always the case
yeah and but what has stayed with me is
like the man from the show with a little
thirst in him
yeah i mean it's just it's so it's
natural yeah
and i feel like thirsty has become a
derogatory word when i think it's just a
natural state of being i think it's a
synonym for hard-working
that is so brilliant and so true
and like why is it admirable to be
hard-working but it's like derogatory to
be thirsty
i think there's c is like a good thing
if i may just please
what i imagine where the connotations
come from like hard working
like implies hard work whereas like
thirstiness implies like social climbing
social climbing in like a desperation to
get where you're going as opposed to
like a commitment no that tracks like
i'm definitely desperate to go
anywhere yeah but desperation and
ambitious also
another example of society putting us
down
yeah always always um
next story speaking of celebrity memoirs
today uh fifth harmony's ali brooke
fears shall die a virgin her memoir
that's a
dramatic headline yeah no i know when i
read it i was like um
her memoir finding her harmony harmony
is out now
and oh i think i would buy that she made
headlines when she revealed that she's
at 27 still a virgin but she exclusively
told page six that there have been
temptations
i mean it is a difficult road especially
being a young woman in the entertainment
business
you're surrounded by attractive people i
stop the temptation by killing the mood
it's like seeing a nice person in the
mall you really want to buy it but you
have to save your money so you walk
around the mall thinking about the purse
if all else fails there's always prayer
she says oh god yes there were times
when i was like lord give me the
strength to make it through this
so in the book is she a virgin for
religious reasons
yes she said um i pray to god like
please don't let me die a virgin let me
meet my husband before that happens to
me and give me a few good ears with him
well that's so sweet i mean honestly
like the virgin shaming that
occurs in society and it really came to
a head with colton's season of the
bachelor
and i'm literally by no means like a
defender of colton but like
it was super mean like how it became
like a joke and i feel like there's
literally maybe i mean i'm very actually
very like old school in a lot of ways
i think there's literally nothing wrong
with being a virgin and like the drama
like
vision like who [ __ ] cares no i i
don't think there's anything wrong with
being a virgin i think waiting
till you're married it's lovely have sex
is a beautiful
thing and if you want to do it great you
want to [ __ ] a million people too cool
love that for you too
also a beautiful thing also a beautiful
thing like it's it's all good you guys
it's
all good it's all good in the hood yeah
but this book actually does sound good
i mean obviously what i want to hear
from her is the destruction of the
greatest girl band of all time
girl group not banned because they don't
play any instruments
um i would love to hear more about that
and like
more like logistics like at what moment
like where were you were you sitting on
the couch like when you found out camila
was leaving were you surprised
yeah what had happened before that yeah
was it weird that like she was clearly
like made the star of the group
yeah and that she was a lot of people's
favorites i don't know if she's people's
favorites anymore i would say maybe
normani is but
was like when you're 15 and like you
care so much about like what people
think of you
and you're in a girl group where like
everyone is obsessed with this one girl
like it has to be destructive for your
mental health
no i know and i feel like so that should
probably be in the memoir and on the one
hand i'd be like no maybe it's her story
about her and that she doesn't focus on
that but the title is finding her
harmony
and so like i think that's a little too
clickbaity a hundred percent she's not
going to talk about it it's a good name
for a book
really good finding your harmony yeah
you know what actually um
what i i mean i'm only like 10 of the
way through mariah's book but i'm not
crazy about the name
the meaning of mariah so i'm glad you
brought this up because it leads me back
to an interesting point
because when i got the book i just kind
of assumed the name was going to be all
that glitters
like because that's who she is that's
actually
a title of one of the four sections in
the book okay the four sections are
wayward child
sing-sing which is a brilliant play on
singing it's a prison yeah and it's the
house that she built to live in with
tommy mathola and like she sang her way
into the house and then it became a
present sing-sing
got it um all that glitters which is
about like the glitter era
and emancipation like emancipation and
like where she's at now
and so i thought the way that it was
structured was so great
but when i came back to it the meaning
of mariah
i think it actually it it ultimately
sums up the book once you're finished
with it but when you're starting it
you're like
oh that's not necessarily like a
celebrity like a catchy name
you know i mean i think i understand why
she named that the book because in order
to understand like all the things she's
been through you need to understand the
meaning of mariah
like where she came from and like her
very traumatic childhood but i'm just
not crazy about the name
okay okay and it's also the meaning of
mariah
carey which like the double m is good
but the carrie
ruins it no but it's the meaning of
mariah on the front cover it says the
meaning of mariah carey oh
because it's also like her name for the
authorship got it so it's just confusing
got it
okay our fifth and final story um
snl host adele finds a reason to sing in
bachelor sketch
snl sung all the way around s
adele sung all the way around at snl and
i want to talk about
her because we each watched the whole
episode what a treat to see adele
what a trait i mean yes the bachelor
sketch was far and away the best one
because she was singing but i felt like
comedically it wasn't no but she
actually has a good like comedic timing
some people who like aren't actors
or like comedians train like they're
singers or their whatever
doing snl like it can be hard to get
that kind of timing but i feel like
adele definitely and it's because when
you if you've been to one of her shows
she talks a lot between songs she's like
a person
a funny person like if you like and i
feel like that's kind of in her vibe in
hollywood too now like she's
very much like in the cool group in
hollywood like her and jennifer lawrence
are such good friends hairstyles
she's also funny i feel like she is just
like a funny girl
yes so she definitely had that timing
like in her monologue
in some of her sketches so i thought it
really elevated a lot of her parts in
different sketches including the
bachelor one like her timing was
actually very good
and of course her voice was unbelievable
and sometimes when you have a british
accent like things just sound funnier
like catch me next week on love island
like that was very funny
yeah she was great she was she was
really great i was glad that we heard
her sing i thought her monologue like
stunk it wasn't a monologue it was just
like hey i'm adele and i'm here because
i didn't finish my album yet yeah
um i feel like she had to explain she
could have sung during her monologue
too so did you tell me if you feel this
like was there like a weirdness how like
just like everyone was looking and of
course adele's like one of the greatest
singers everyone was like looking for
her to sing and like
why aren't you the performer blah blah
which is just like kind of like a slap
in the face to her
100 percent okay i felt like there was a
disrespect towards her i
felt the exact same way because like it
was the adele show yeah
it's like it i felt like
that what it like not a great week to be
the i mean it's always a good week to be
on snl because it's like such an honor
but
i i would have felt like a little it was
almost like because adele was the
host and not the performers like we were
settling for her like that's what the
the the conversation around them being
on snl felt like and i felt like it was
just like
the whole episode just like everything
was like a slight towards her yeah
because no just everyone was talking
about odell about everything when we're
talking about the music from snl this
week we're talking about the bachelor
yeah
um adele did break her character on that
african um
commercial thing which of all the
sketches like i didn't think was that
funny and i don't know why she couldn't
stop laughing like
it's not that funny no i didn't and a
lot of times when someone breaks during
the sketch it actually makes the sketch
funnier because it's like oh my god
they're having such a good time
and i was just like why are we laughing
so hard yeah it ain't that funny no
my favorite sketch was the pete davidson
chad in the haunted house 100 when he
was like
spooky and she's like he's like cool
yeah uh crazy bathroom
no that was really funny also like and i
could say this about any episode like
what where what does pete davidson do
like no he's not in
every time he's on snl like i feel
awkward yeah i'm like i remember
i remember all of his interviews and
stand up where he like talks about how
he's like the outcast of snl i'm like oh
my god you're still here
yeah no and it's just like it's so
bizarre to me that like the most famous
person on the cast
arguably like in terms of mainstream
media is never on the show
yeah i mean he talks about that a lot
he's always just waiting to get fired it
sounds like
yeah maybe but like but he hasn't gotten
fired yeah maybe maybe like embrace
it i don't embrace him i don't know but
i agree that haunted house sketch was
very funny and the psychic sketch was
hysterical
yes like of what's going to happen in
2020. but like once again it's just kate
mckinnon
is i don't watch snl all the time but
when i do i come back to the theory
it's not a theory the fact that kate
mckinnon like is the glue
that holds it together kate mckinnon and
kenan puts yes and keenan put their show
on their backs
i completely agree not only are they
literally in every single sketch and
they play like such a broad range of
characters
people who you wouldn't think they even
look like but they're the funniest
yeah i hope kenan and kate mckinnon make
more money than the others me too
i think they do you know who's actually
growing on me who that guy from the 18t
commercials
which one is he mike bennett oh is he
he's always like playing like a serious
guy
he played the bachelor yeah he's growing
on me
yeah i feel that i don't know what his
background is but i know that he was on
the those viral a t commercials with the
kids like you would go into like
kindergarten classrooms and be like 5g
you know yeah yeah 4g actually
interesting yeah but it was a good
episode of snl love seeing adele she
looked amazing she obviously addressed
the fact
oh right that she looks so vastly
different um she just like
literally without fail i've never seen
her without perfect hair and makeup like
whoever does her foch is an artist
she looked amazing sorry that was the
other part that i want to talk about
obviously everyone's talking about her
physical transformation
and we've seen photos here and there and
everyone's like she looks so different
but we got to see it in high definition
getting to see her like
in her element the looks the the styling
the dress that she wore for her bachelor
confessional with like the feather
sickening the nails the liner the hair
the skin
everything about her she is like so
stunning she's always been stunning
she's always had like the face of an
angel and she was just like
it was a good night to be adele on
saturday and you could feel it you could
feel her confidence yeah
and it was just it was a beautiful thing
to just like watch someone being so
radiant because there's
there's not that so much of that right
now yeah and feeling so like confident
and sure of themselves and like having
fun i was like jealous of the time she
was having yeah like i'm sure the after
party was
lit i don't know if they're doing after
parties because of i feel like they're
doing after gatherings
yeah well i mean everyone has anything
right so like they just should
have an after gathering at the office
yeah like i'm sure they're finding a way
to celebrate
um colin jost love my life did you see
that um
him and scarlett johansson's save the
date like went viral because it was
literally like a piece of loose leaf it
was on an index card
yeah it was like a joke yeah it's like
haha like i didn't find a bunny me
neither it's like
kind of rude okay i'm glad you agree
yeah like send out first of all save
send out a save the date and like to
joke about having like a low budget like
trying to save money when your wife is
the highest paid actress
in hollywood and like you literally are
on one of the number one television
shows every single week like just felt
it felt a little deaf i agree okay um
tv recap segment real housewives of
potomac i have actually a lot i want to
say about it
um brought to you by vega vega has one
goal to help you power your story with
premium plant
based nutrition that enables you to feel
and perform your best learn more about
how to power your story
with vega at myvega.com
toast if you're looking to upgrade your
daily smoothie or level up your
afternoon snack
vega has you covered from protein
powders to bars made with real
plant-based ingredients and you can
upgrade your recipes smoothies and
nutrition
routine with vega they're made with real
plant-based ingredients vega
products are plant-based gluten-free
non-gmo project verified
and vegan certified level up your next
smoothie or snack with delicious
plant-based protein also if you're
looking for some immune support which in
you know these unprecedented times
everyone should be looking to boost
their immunity
if you're looking for delicious options
with nutrients to help support your
immune system
vega has you covered with vega 1 or vega
protein and greens
with delicious protein powders and daily
vitamins made with real plant-based
ingredients
you can nourish yourself from the inside
out learn more at myvega.com
toast so m-y-v-e-g-a
dot com slash toast is how you spell it
fabulous time to boost your immunity
start taking better care of yourself
with smoothies or anything to boost your
immune system that's my
vega.com toast a fabulous line of
products we actually have them in the
studio so if you ever want to drop it in
your coffee or
smoothie if you want to come over we
have some myvega.com
toast they also have vegas sport which
has you covered pre-mid and post-workout
so it's made with real plant-based
ingredients vegas for it has a wide
range of plant-based protein powders and
supplements
to help you power your story learn more
at myvega.com
toast thank you vega for sponsoring
today's tv recap segment real houses of
potomac
let's get into it good episode better
better
we're getting there um so a lot actually
happened on social media
that i was following this morning after
last night's episode because somebody
tweeted that
like obviously another slow down slow-mo
version of the fight
we're actually in an attempt to separate
them giselle
pushed monique before the wineglass
throwing before the hair flipping
giselle pushed money and karen huger
quote tweeted it was like yeah like
you're gonna see her web of lies like
becomes unraveled
it's much deeper and it's not even far
from being over because there's so much
more to go
but this episode was frustrating it was
good but as a monique stan
um she's really losing me like a hundred
percent really i think that
okay you want everyone to see how much
you've grown and i and i'm so glad that
she's at a place where she like
genuinely feels remorse and like wants
the women to know that she
is on a good path i just think like
inviting them to your live podcast was
probably the worst thing you could have
done but it was planned before
all of this happened so what does she
need to do no she no i'm saying still do
it
but to invite robin and wendy
to the to this specific event to make
them see your growth like that's not
really how it works it just felt
very bizarre to me and like the way she
was just like
plowing through them on the phone calls
like okay we want to come
it was just it was very bizarre to me
and i feel like she has good intentions
but her method for like getting back
in the good graces of the women and like
wanting her them to see how much she's
changed like her plan is not good
well i mean i just she had this plan and
like obviously we know
it's a live podcast like i'm sure a lot
of people were there like hoping to see
some of the women for potomac so like
she doesn't expect them all to come but
she's gonna at least try and get some of
them there to
like get buzzed for her event we don't
know what she talked about on the show
but even when someone asked like a
a question about candice again she could
have been petty and she just said pray
for us like she really was trying to
take the high road like
i i understand while in that instance
you're not gonna be able to see like
monique has changed or if she has
changed
but like if you want to see that change
like
you have to show up and let these things
happen
not just like sure it's just it's not as
cutting dry as like okay when you come
to this like i'm going to be ready to
show you
no i know but it's like if you really
want to show people
your growth i just think it's weird to
invite them to an event it's like
not intimate first of all second of all
monique's not gonna be able to talk to
them she's busy working like
the stage and putting on a show it just
seemed like a very bizarre first step
for her to take
obviously self-promotional she had like
a few interests in it which i totally
understand and respect the business
hustle
but it just seemed very strange like i
don't think anyone's gonna get to see
her real
growth and her progress when she's on
stage like performing like that made no
sense to me well i mean
i i would maybe agree with you and i do
sort of i see where you're coming from
but then if you look at the event that
wendy had i feel like
in so many ways it did bring the women
together and they were having great
conversations and yes wendy was on stage
but they were
listening to her on stage and like
feeling so inspired by her and having so
much respect but wendy didn't invite
them there with the intention of like
showing their her growth it was just
like a good event that's like a natural
byproduct of what can happen when you
see someone in their element and you
just like have
more respect for them you know and so i
as much as yes
monique wouldn't have gone on the stage
and been like i am so remorseful and and
this is how i change but did you think
i agree with you working hard and like
and doing
whatever they're trying to do and if
it's good and it's positive like
you do see people in a different
language versus them in their workplaces
that's the best first step to take i
think it was the first thing that came
up like that's just where
the pla like how like she could have
reached out to other other women like
and had like one on one sit down at
karen's house
she did but she didn't put that together
she did she asked karen to put it
together
oh i guess i mean to me like honestly
and i love her
she's just so messy and like she makes
no sense there's no right way of going
about things when everybody just
is only going to see the bad in you it's
always going to come off wrong
yeah but part of like actual growth and
like progress is like being able to
like swallow your pride and take [ __ ]
from people and i feel like that's the
one thing that monique really struggled
it was when she swallowed her pride and
took [ __ ]
when they sat at karen's house no
because she literally said like you
don't think she's swallowing her pride
and taking [ __ ] while she's home and
every single event that the women are
hosting she's not invited to
she no i don't think so no literally at
the event i think her biggest problem
was her inability to just like be
like be in the wrong like literally ever
like and they were coming at her like a
little too hard but like
she just struggles i think so much with
like and first of all her the way she
acted at karen singh was like
really not great like if she and she
said it took her like two weeks to like
realize she was wrong which is
kind of [ __ ] up but but okay it took
her two weeks so that event karen's to
me was like
was not good for monique like in any way
she said she had no remorse
but even if whatever led her to like
physically attacking someone like
you gotta have remorse yeah but it she
has remorse now like
it takes time like sometimes you think
of like when you get so mad about
something
you're so mad and that you act
irrationally irrationally
and after the fact you're like cemented
in the fact like oh yeah i needed to do
this like
and then eventually you come down from
it and you're like
maybe that wasn't the best way you have
perspective she shouldn't have asked
karen to set up that thing for her
if she was still in the place where she
was still seeing okay but then if like
she hadn't reached out to the women and
try and
talk to them until she was remorseful
two weeks would have gone by and they
were like
plus you were silent for two weeks yeah
no it's an impossible situation to be in
and i don't know what the right thing
for monique
to do moving forward is but i just know
like everything she's doing is like
making me like
les it's making it less and less easy to
like support her
i feel really good about supporting you
and you know who i
just am huger karen hugher i love
cameron everything she said in that
conversation with candace and then wendy
was so on point was just straight
facts and of course they're all going to
like
take it personally and and karen is
defending monique and
and i'm sure now that karen's not even
no i know but that's how they're going
to see it because she's not on candace's
side and i just love that karen hugo is
so
strong and so sure of herself and so has
such like
she's so principled she's so principled
and knows like
and has her moral confidence it's
totally angry and just because someone
doesn't like what she's saying she's not
gonna say something else
and just because everyone's feeling a
certain way doesn't mean she's gonna
feel that way and i had
so much respect for her and like i
couldn't have said it what she said i
could not have said it i will not be
battered into submission
yeah and when she called candace a child
a young woman
and then i'll watch what happens if i
you know ashley and giselle were like
you know when can't
when karen's calling someone a young
woman like you know it's not good like
no no she was being a an immigrant
person
and needed to be put in her place i
could not agree more that actually that
conversation was really frustrating and
wendy was bothering me
so much because at the end of the day
it's between candace and karen they
didn't need her there it didn't get out
of hand these are two
you know grown women who were having a
very adult conversation even though they
were disagreeing
they didn't need a moderator a referee
there and and wendy just makes it so
unbalanced because she's
so blindly loyal to candace which is
also not a good way to be
so she was really bothering me but i
feel like karen did not let like the two
of them kind of ganging up on her derail
her at all she was so poised
and she got her point across and i
totally agreed with her and she said
like
candace in the past like you have done
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and i've never
like to take in the other person's side
100 like i always and
and candace is just so rational she's
like i just need you to admit that like
what monique did was 100 wrong
and then they flashed back to karen's
house where she literally said that like
right it's just
it's like only hearing what you want to
hear right and when wendy comes in and
she's like karen if you would just say
this and it's like
that's i hate that [ __ ] when it's like
just say exactly what i want you to say
and you'll be okay like that's not how
the world works that's not how people
work
everybody has a different way of
communicating and feeling and we're not
all going to say the same things and
it's not going to be
exactly what you want to hear like and i
just love that karen was like
underground now i actually thought
wendy's event was really nice i thought
it was wonderful
and like it's crazy because it was
filmed like a year ago but it still
still feels very appropriate now because
the election's coming up and
that's where like i love wendy but in
terms of the drama i think she came in
in a really tough spot
and you know what this whole season is
very difficult because i think like
overall like
nobody is disliked more by the audience
than candace
but candace is now truly like the victim
and she's also
living milking oh literally she's like
how are you literally no
nobody nobody nobody canis i've been
having panic attacks like
she's just insufferably like playing
into this
role but at the end of the day yes
monique did initiate that fight but like
candace had
uh to has to take responsibility for her
part in it also i do feel like my
opinion on this is kind of skewed
because we've seen that slow down
footage and from what i've seen like
aside from the hair flicking which isn't
like necessary
which isn't like a the p putting your
hands on someone like it's not not but
it's not
fully like making it physical candice
put her hands on monique first in the
slow down video that i saw
so i'm like watching everything through
the lens of like
yes it got super heated and monique had
a really big part in that but like
it from what i saw candace put
her hands on monique's body best first
so also then next week monique is
obviously like counter-suing and i think
that's where candace like gets really
freaked out because at the end of the
day monique has
more means to fight this legally like
the money for legal bills like monique
definitely has that over candice
and i don't know part of me is kind of
like
yeah get in there get in there money
yeah it's just it's a really tough
position to be in
oh and that's what i'm saying for wendy
like so wendy came in and as the new
girl
she has no choice but to be completely
loyal to candace
which is a tough thing to do because
honestly even outside of this fight like
candace is just the worst
yeah like over like overarching like
outside of this fight just like as a
cast mate and if it weren't for this
fight
this fight bought her another two
seasons like candace is just
the the worst yeah and the whole season
is like
now filmed in like the lens
of this fight and it's just like
we i i'm ready to move on from it you
know yeah but it's it's the cornerstone
for everything
yeah so they're going to portugal does
everyone go i don't think monico's
doesn't look like she was invited like
was in the footage but i don't know
but isn't who's the one who opens up the
flag and it's like actually
so ashley if it's ashley's trip monique
would be invited okay that's true and it
seems like
the trips are obviously planned by bravo
so the person who like brings it to the
group
is strategically done so so i actually
feel like maybe monique does go
okay true i don't know but i mean i
don't know i don't know how she can i
mean
it's painfully awkward yeah oh and then
the whole other part of the episode with
robin and juan in the ring and like just
ask me if i care
do you no i don't so i don't want to
talk about it
great i wasn't going to but we did see a
little jamal bryant and i know we're
like supposed to hate him because like
he's unfaithful and like has
children with like a million women but i
just love him yeah the car the
conversation in the car was interesting
and it was cute and i'm glad they're on
the same page and of course the way that
they teased it was like
just but she was like said that and i
was like but i would never do that yeah
wait no but i don't do that so we're not
like i love her um even though like
she's definitely like sneaky
oh for sure she definitely has her hands
all over the place yeah no i i like
literally never agree with her
role but i just live in the fight i just
yeah i like her
i just never agree with her but i agree
like after this episode my respect for
karen hugher is just like
and honestly after the last few episodes
like when we saw her hometown it made me
love her so much more and she's been
killing these looks killing i'm just
completely
and totally here for her i have so much
respect for her and
i feel like in a way she's really like
the moral compass of the show and
honestly i never thought i would say
that after
like her first few seasons she was
inseparable mm-hmm but i love her
love um central house was a potomac
tomorrow we have
no the bachelor's we have the night off
thank god and we have oc housewives and
kardashians
and it's just gonna be a fabulous week
yeah great week so
anything you want to say no i think that
that is all that she had written
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so that's spotify itunes
stitcher public video i have ready to
cast box all the places we're now
available on amazon music
so wherever you listen to your podcast
find us the morning toast and leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
we hope you have an amazing monday don't
let the monday blues get you down and
we'll see you tomorrow
goodbye